[Music]
people love superheroes they swooped out
of the sky and save the day
people love that cozy feeling they
simply ask given my deepest condolences
to Robyn's family she just stepped in
the middle of the street you know she
was a half step off the [ __ ] car down
come on Hughie just gonna upset Supes
lose hundreds of people each year it's a
collateral damage it's [ __ ]
diabolical they're all like that all of
them yeah
pardon my french [ __ ] those [ __ ] I've
got the boys to give up
Jonas yeah something wet suspect the
bastard the robbing
you've suicide to go after the Supes we
can use help stuffing now excuse me I'm
sorry are you okay I'm fine I'm just
having a bad day it's a work thing I'm
supposed to be this hero Idol symbol but
I don't know what the hell I'm doing she
could help us she's a super just
arrested them you're all about her
just remember William Flint's enemies ha
they just declared war
you can't do this you don't have the
fight you never have
this kid is full surprises
well well well if you know what it looks
like I thought we had an understanding I
know you're trying to be tough but we're
superheroes
[Music]